[Musique]
te regarder tu dois te rappeler
tombé là-bas ce n'était pas humain l'armée
et il a encore tué ils ne l'ont pas juste
tué piraté leur vie est
partout je ne le trouverai plus et
ensuite nous le tuerons
toi  ne parle jamais de ton passé ne te
souviens pas de la femme enceinte il y a eu une
attaque tu étais en train de mourir nous t'avons sauvé et
maintenant tu sauves les autres tout ce qu'ils t'ont dit
était un mensonge tu ajoutes une famille souviens toi de
ça mais moi
quelle beauté tu es
veux tu de moi ils  ne t'a pas sauvé
la vie ils l'ont volé
combien étaient là avant moi
elle était le poste a eu une pause nette
je t'ordonne de mettre fin
au ramassage
ils m'ont créé mais ils ne peuvent pas me contrôler
toi